you
wildstar a deep sprawling space
adventure set on the mysterious planet
Nexus this isn't just another sci-fi MMO
with pretty colors it's a completely new
frontier know what else the gameplays
can awesome
plain and simple wild starts combat
kicks ass
aim dodge sprint and double jump your
way into glorious combat nirvana
or things like position and movement
really matter gear up put them in your
sights and explode your enemies oh yeah
but after those epic battles you'll need
a place to kick it so we've made player
housing ridiculous customize anything
your twisted little brain can imagine
and invite your friends to bask in the
sheer majesty of your galacto fabulous
space crib mmm take it in
and speaking of customization it goes
way beyond player housing we let you
personalize everything how you look are
you craft how you fight how you
adventure and best of all how you
think you got the skills to pay the
bills wildstar's battlegrounds and
arenas let you take on other players for
casual thrills or some serious
competition and in the open world mark
and hunt down your rivals for that
sweeter culture of satisfying game then
there's warplots
epic 40 versus 40 battles with fully
customizable death fortresses and by the
way you can level up entirely through
PvP maybe you're more into some
old-school adventuring we've got you
covered
did you say that big storyline yeah we
got that do one second you'll be
exploring a creepy elven laboratory and
the next you'll throw on low gravity and
super double jump to an ancient ruin in
Adventures groups make choices and
explore multiple paths through the
caretakers sadistically elaborate
simulations or maybe you're ready for
the next level wildstar's dungeons can
take you there with epic bosses and
gameplay mechanics you won't believe
then there's raids we turn them up to
infinity seriously don't rip your face
off
Parker can I be honest here all this
stuff is just the tip of the iceberg
there's more lots more and we're just
getting the start
so what are you waiting for wildstar
will be here soon and it is full of
mystery adventure and pure unadulterated
awesome sighs the only thing missing is
you